[Music]
from los angeles
please welcome the president of the
academy david rubin
good morning everyone i'm coming to you
from the academy museum of motion
pictures
at the entrance to the oscars experience
where you'll soon be able to feel all
the excitement
of standing on the oscar stage yourself
with the museum's official opening
coming this fall fans will explore
behind the scenes of their favorite
movies
and discover the magic of filmmaking in
person
this morning is an annual tradition when
we announce the nominations for the
oscars
all the nominees are selected by members
of the academy
a diverse community of filmmakers from
around the world
before i turn it over to priyanka chopra
jonas and nick jonas
who are joining us live from london i'm
delighted to share that this year's
oscar ceremony
will take place april 25th at both la's
historic
union station and the landmark dolby
theater
and now it's time to deliver what you've
all been waiting for the nominees
priyanka and nick over to you
[Music]
thank you so much david and good morning
although we're in london so it's
afternoon here
but regardless of a time of day it's a
moment that each of these nominees will
never forget
absolutely first up the nominee is
chosen by members of the academy's
actors branch
actress in a supporting role
maria bakalova in borat subsequent movie
film
delivery of prodigious bribe to american
regime
for make benefit once glorious nation of
kazakhstan
glenn close in hillbilly elegy
olivia coleman in the father
amanda seyfried in manc
and year jong-un in congratulations to
all those nominees
our next category is best costume design
with nominees voted by the academy's
costume designers branch
emma
ma rainey's black bottom
mulan and pinocchio
and now here are the nominees for best
original score
voted by the academy's music branch
defy bloods
mank meenari
news of the world and
soul this is so exciting so fun
the writers branch nominates screenplays
in two award categories
best adapted screenplay and best
original screenplay
first is best adapted screenplay
borat subsequent movie film delivery of
prodigious bribe to american regime
for make benefit once glorious nation of
kazakhstan
sasha baron cohen anthony hines
dan swimer peter bainham
erica rivenoya dan mazer
jenna friedman and lee kern
story by sasha baron cohen anthony heinz
dan sweimer and nina pedrad
the father christopher hampton and
florian
zeller nomadland
chloe zhao
one night in miami kemp powers
and the white tiger rameen behrani
ah yes congrats rameen
and now the nominees for best original
screenplay
judas and the black messiah will
berson and shocker king story
by will burson shocker king kenny lucas
and keith lucas
minari lee isaac chung
promising young woman emerald finnell
sound of metal darius martyr
and abraham martyr story
by darius martyr and derek c in france
and the trial of the chicago seven
aaron sorkin aaron sorkin is he a newbie
yeah
well since you did two in a row i think
i'm going to announce two
short film categories both overseen by
the short films and feature animation
branch
for best animated short film here are
the nominees
burro
genius loci
if anything happens i love you
opera and yes
people for best
live action short film the nominees are
feeling through
the letter room
the present
two distant strangers
and white eye congratulations to
everyone
now the nominees for an actor in a
supporting role
they are
sasha baron cohen in the trial of the
chicago seven
daniel kaluya in judas and the black
messiah
leslie odom jr in one night in miami
paul rassi in sound of metal
and lakeith stanfield in judas and the
black messiah
congratulations we still have more
nominee announcements we'll be back at 5
31 pdt
stay tuned
[Music]
a martini shaken monster they call me
mr tips i
am the father
you can't handle the truth always do the
right thing
all right mr demille i'm ready for my
close-up you're gonna need a bigger boat
[Music]
and i want to be
[Music]
let's go
[Music]
let's start the show
[Music]
let's start the show
[Music]
oh
yeah i want to be mine
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back or if you just got up and
are joining us
now welcome let's continue with the
nominations
members of the academy's documentary
branch have chosen these nominees for
best
documentary feature and they are
collective
[ __ ] camp
the mole agent my octopus teacher
and time for best documentary short
subject here are the nominees
colette
a concerto is a conversation
do not split
hunger ward and a love song for latasha
congratulations everyone the nominees
for best
international feature film were voted on
by academy members from
all branches living and working outside
all over the world the nominees are
another round denmark
better days hong kong
collective romania
the man who sold his skin tunisia
bosnia and herzegovina very nice with
pronunciation
well done thank you thank you thank you
the sound branch of the academy chooses
the nominees for best achievement
in sound they are
greyhound
mank news of the world
soul and sound
of metal
the production design branch nominates
these films for best production design
the father
ma rainey's black bottom
mank
news of the world
congratulations here are the nominees
for best film editing
chosen by members of the academy's film
editors branch
the father
no mad land
promising young woman
sound of metal
and the trial of the chicago seven
the academy's cinematograph
cinematographers branch nominate the
following for best cinematography
judas and the black messiah
mank news of the world
nomad land and the trial of the chicago
seven lots of nominations
lots of nominations the visual effects
branch voted for these films to be the
nominees for best visual effects
love and monsters
the midnight sky
mulan
the one and only ivan
and tenant
when you think of me you naturally think
of best makeup and hairstyling
however they didn't let me vote uh
instead the members of that academy
branch nominate the following films
emma hillbilly elegy
ma rainey's black bottom
mank and pinocchio
this next category is voted on by short
films and feature animation branch
as well as members of the animation
community across all branches
here are the nominees for best animated
feature film
onward
over the moon
a sean the sheep movie farmageddon
so
and wolf walkers
and now here is the other category voted
on by the music branch
here are their nominees for best
original song
fight for you judas and the black
messiah
hear my voice from the trial of the
chicago seven
hussevic from eurovision song contest
the story of fire saga
eoc scene from the life ahead la vita
de vante assay
and speak now from one night in miami
for actor in a leading role the actors
branch members nominate
riz ahmed in sound of metal
chadwick boseman in maharani's black
bottom
anthony hopkins in the father
gary oldman in bank
and stephen young in minari
congratulations to all those incredible
nominees for actress in a leading role
the nominees are
viola davis in mahreni's black bottom
andre day and the united states first
billy holiday
vanessa kirby in pieces of a woman
francis mcdormand in nomad land
and carrie mulligan and promising young
woman all
amazing performances for directing
the academy directors branch has chosen
these nominees
thomas winterberg another round
david fincher mank
lee isaac chung minari
chloe zhao nomadland
and emerald fennell promising young
woman
and finally the nominees for best
picture voted by all members of the
academy are
okay ready ready
the father david parfit jean-louis levy
and philippe carcasson producers
judas and the black messiah shakka king
charles d king
and ryan coogler producers
mank c n chafin eric roth
and douglas urbanski producers
minari christina oh producer
no mad land francis mcdormand peter
spears
molly asher dan janvi and chloe zhao
producers
promising young woman ben browning
ashley fox
emerald fennell and josie mcnamara
producers
sound of metal bert hemlink and sasha
ben hirosh
producers
and last the trial of the chicago seven
mark platt and stuart besser producers
well i am already strategizing my oscars
pool congratulations to
all of these incredible nominees wow
what a year and thank you for joining us
and
watch the oscars live on sunday april
25th
only on abc bye
[Music]
you